shipping is crucial to the global
economy and vital for getting us the
stuff that we want when we want it but
few of us ever give any of this much
thought the computer or phone that
you're watching this on the clothes
you're wearing even the coffee you're
drinking probably came by ship and the
container ships that carry all that
around are amongst the largest vehicles
ever built but dealing with their
contents is a growing challenge ports
are running at full capacity and choke
points mean delays this enormous ship is
the Merce Essex and it can hold up to
six thousand five hundred of these
regular 40-foot long containers this is
actually all holiday Goods coming in for
the season and if you were to take every
one of these containers off now and line
them up on trucks they would stretch a
hundred and twelve miles that's the size
of the problem and 80% of these
containers will be lifted off or more
will be put back on at this one quart
alone the port of LA is the number one
in the US by container volume as you
might guess the lead-up to the holidays
and our crass consumerism makes this one
of the busiest periods a surge in
containers can lead to bottlenecks
and in the worst case scenario lines of
ships out at sea laden with our
potential purchases now the port of LA
is trying something new it's working
with GE to capture as much data as
possible and to share it as widely as
possible they'll create an information
portal to give everyone more planning
time and to hopefully make things run a
little smoother you know typically the
port terminal operators and all of the
different parties in the process find
out about the cargo on that ship where
it's going what its inbound destination
is about 48 hours in advance of it
hitting port you know tomorrow with this
solution that data will be unlocked and
be available about two weeks in advance
of the port a pilot program for
information sharing will be run next
year for around two or three months but
the hope is to prove how useful it is
and of course keep it going it will take
everyone playing together to work from
the terminal operators to the shipping
companies to the customs authorities the
port of LA will be the first to try such
an integrated system
something like it's going to be crucial
to keep our global supply chain moving